[Music]  no award shows complete without a  self-important cause for that we turn to  Andy Richter Thank You Conan as you know  there's only one requirement to be  eligible for an audience e you have to  be able to clap  sadly countless people in this country  have never learned how to applaud  properly that's why I Andy Richter  support clap the Center for learning  applause proficiency each year clap  gives thousands of non clappers a new  lease on clapping whether you like the  motor skills you're afraid of the danger  involved or you're just played stupid  clap will give you the confidence you  need to bang your hands together over  and over again just a spokesman for clap  I'm also a graduate just four weeks ago  I'd never clapped in my life and now now  look at me  [Applause]  and  that's very good Andy Thank You Conan  you know